[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines now with
the director of demos think tank polly
mckenzie and chief political
correspondent at the daily telegraph
christopher hope they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
gas levy against the green light is the
lead story in the times which says the
government will announce attacks on gas
bills to fund low carbon heating despite
soaring prices
the telegraph claims the government
could scale back free lateral flow and
pcr testing amid concern among senior
government ministers over the cost to
the public purse
meanwhile the financial times leads on a
worldwide corporate tax agreement that
will see a minimum rate of 15 percent
implemented across 136 countries raising
over 100 billion pounds a year in tax
the daily mail reports on plans for a
new 888 emergency phone number for women
in response to the murder of sarah
everard which could be up and running by
christmas
a former tesco boss has been called in
by boris johnson to save christmas
amongst supply shortages that is on the
front of the express
the front of the guardian looks at the
impact of tick-tock anti-vax social
media posts on children
and it is crunch time according to the
star which reports the price of crisps
and snacks could rock it
now we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and christopher hope good
evening to both of you so we're going to
turn first of all uh to the front of the
mail polly uh which has news of a new
phone number for women walking home at
night the walk me home service
yeah this is a proposal that bt put to
government
uh
as a result of the sarah evard case you
know so much concern about
making women more safe in the street but
also giving more women the confidence
that they uh can call on the authorities
that they are being protected the
proposal here is in a way replicating
what millions of women do informally
with their friends you know i've often
walked home and stayed on the line to
you know friend a family member just so
that you know that
somebody will know if anything bad has
happened and i'm you know i'm sure lots
of people will say you know text me when
you get home so that there is that sense
of reassurance this will be a more
formal system either through a phone app
uh where you could basically allow it to
share your location
uh presumably um
you'd have to tell it where you were
going so that it knew if you had gone
off track exactly how that would work is
it's kind of still to be ironed out or
possibly a phone number this 888 is a
suggested number it's not a phone number
that you can just immediately call this
is a proposal that's being worked out
but what the mail is reporting is that
pretty patel has has backed this bt idea
yeah and christopher she has apparently
described as exactly the kind of
innovative scheme which would be good to
get going as soon as we can she's
looking into it
i mean it sounds positive in the short
term doesn't it it's something to give
women more confidence but yet again this
is a solution that puts the onus on
women
that's right you know i mean the issue
for pretty patel is you know how can you
restore faith in the police service and
and you know why isn't there a false a
full inquiry into the metropolitan
police after the after the the this
murder of sarah everard by the policeman
it's unbelievable really i i mean it's
um it's a good idea from philip jansen
he's the ceo of of bt it might cost as
little as 50 million pounds but as you
say it does it's it's kind of
formalizing what polly says so
eloquently
oh and just as we were talking about
speaking eloquently we've oh christopher
we've got you back we lost you mid-flow
there
apology i just said it's just saying how
well um polly was talking about it there
that the you know you would text um uh
an estimate of when you might get home
to the 888 number or download a mobile
app and that's a way of tracking you and
getting you home i mean it's a way of
doing it but it doesn't quite get the
point of the lack of faith in the police
service is not addressed by this at all
it comes polly on the day we've had dame
louise casey baroness louise casey
appointed uh to look into
culture at the metropolitan police
yeah so i mean louise casey is a
formidable woman uh first came to kind
of the public eye
uh when she for tony blair ran an
initiative to massively massively reduce
street homelessness incredibly
successful went on to be an anti-social
behaviors are uh then to uh do a project
looking at how you help the most
troubled families uh to deal with their
problems and get back on track so she's
she is the sort of um
investigating pioneer who comes in and
sorts things out she's a great name
good choice i think the problem is that
because it's uh an informal inquiry she
won't necessarily have any powers in
order to to guarantee that she gets hold
of the papers will be reliant on the
metropolitan police to comply you would
think given that they've appointed her
they would comply but we have seen from
past examples
of inquiries into the mets behavior that
actually
getting that culture of disclosure
is really really difficult and often
they have dragged their heels on
publishing on sharing documents i think
the most important thing
is for the met to open their books up as
much as possible
to louise casey who is an absolutely
kind of trustworthy figure
in that way and be ready and willing to
accept that they may need to change and
that is something that the met i think
has struggled with a lot in the past if
they want public confidence back they
have to accept that something needs to
change yeah it comes down to trust
doesn't it chris for this story is in
the times an inquiry into claims of
sexual abuse by its officers looking
into
allegations made against officers and
the vetting process which has been
much discussed in recent weeks
yeah as polly says uh louise casey
she she takes no prisoners i mean she
will she'll call out any anything she
any obfuscation there's a kind of line
of duty style inquiry um by someone
who's not a policeman and i wonder
whether
there may be ways of of i wonder how
open the met police will be with this
inquiry obviously it's got the maximum
support of crested dick she's there for
two more years so there is a real reason
why this has to do a good job i just
hope that luis casey can get to the
bottom of of what she needs to find out
and it can i can look into his claims of
of of issues within that police i think
it has to be resolved as soon as
possible and it's very important that
they they show they do show what they're
doing here and nothing nothing is hidden
yeah and and when we talk about faith in
the metropolitan police also
in its commissioner dame crested dick
and is christopher saying there she has
a further two years to serve
uh polly
uh you know lots of people called for
quesadilla to go they called for
presidential after the
uh relatively aggressive violent
suppression of the protest the vigil
um
during the covid lockdown i recognized
but nevertheless they were incredibly
brutal with um with womanhood
to honor sarah everard's uh death and
you know this has come to light again
because of all of that evidence we heard
in the sentencing
about precisely the extent to which he
abused his powers
and i think you know
i think for lots of women there has been
that really horrifying recognition that
in that circumstance we would have
gotten that car too and the moment you
have got in that car your debt and that
is just a devastating reality about the
power that police have over us
personally i agree that cressida should
have gone
but
she's she's not gonna go so the way for
her to have some hope of redeeming
herself i think in the eyes of those who
have lost confidence in her is to
absolutely
open the doors open the books let the
light in and use those two years to be a
radically reforming commissioner i
really hope she's got it in her yeah i
mean it's something we've all asked
ourselves as women isn't it what would
we have done
faced with a police officer telling us
we had uh breached covid regular
relations and most of us would have got
in that car uh too um let's turn to the
telegraph now christopher and um a push
to scrap free covered tests concerns
about the cost to the public purse of
the free lateral flow tests and pcr
tests mass testing
this is all about a return to normal
living with with kobid the idea of
moving this story in the telegraph is
that under a new system the free tests
might be only provided
in high risk settings like care homes
hospitals and schools as well as people
with symptoms um and rather having um
them giving out you know we have them at
home here for the children and there's
these these lateral flow tests are
everywhere now aren't they but they cost
this to the taxpayer is enormous um and
we are growing to to live live with with
kobit um and in the same way i think is
a big risk going into this winter with
flu i think this makes some degree of
sense that we have to try and find a way
you know most of us now are vaccinated
and let's start living with a stressful
disease does it make sense as we head
into the autumn and winter polly um to
withdraw free tests from the public
aren't tests part of the government
strategy
tests are a big part of the government's
strategy
chris is right at some point we have to
get rid of this
we you know we will need to move to that
point where we are living with this
disease uh jeremy farah of the welcome
uh trust has suggested uh who serves on
stage that that's perhaps 30 000 cases a
hundred deaths that we're talking about
as a as a level that we might have to
live with and it's uncomfortable to
accept that
uh the question
only for me is when precisely
and we have you know we had that
predicted summer wave that didn't come
thank goodness there is the possibility
of a winter wave and that having
implications i think for me the key
thing is that incentives though still
aren't right for people to take the test
and stay at home if they are infectious
because we still have some of the lowest
sick pay in the in the western developed
world and and that means that if you
feel a bit of a coffin cold it's in your
interest if you don't get sick pay or if
you're self-employed
to just sort of hope um maybe wear a
mask and go out there and i think if
you're going to invest money in public
health interventions personally i would
focus on on yeah concentrating these
tests in those more high-risk settings
and getting the incentives right for
people and improving our sick pay and
we're seeing now a big push on the flu
vaccine encouraging people to have their
flu vaccine because that uh could put
increasing pressure on the nhs uh this
autumn and winter stay with us
christopher and polly we're going to
take a short break when we come back
could the rising cost of living be about
to get even worse we'll be discussing
that after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now polly mckenzie and
christopher hope uh christopher we're
going to turn to uh inside the times now
a warning by factory bosses of closures
with soaring gas prices
yes you've got um bosses here of steel
ceramics chemicals and paper businesses
meeting with quasi-cuatang today the
business secretary uh one of the
closures could happen soon the reason
why is the significant increases in
bills unlike um you and i at home
um these big wholesale um manufacturers
that they give they can't benefit from
the cap on on costs of gas so they are
the price of wholesale gas is soaring by
250 percent
since since the start of the year they
are in energy crisis this will have a
knock-on effect for these key raw
material areas which we may we may find
um coming through towards consumers i'm
not sure how soon that will that will
take but that's the worry i mean the
worry is the fact you start being close
because they can't afford to keep them
open in the old days it was many brick
makers
this is a much bigger scale problem
brickmakers the first ones because they
the amount of energy they use was really
um was so much really and and they were
there was a quite a marginal business
for many of them but to see the scale of
industry warning of closures it shows
what a serious state we're in
and the pms recruited the former boss of
tesco to try and sort out supply chain
issues polly
yes described as uh here to save
christmas in the light of you know
potential shortages
it's a reminder i think all of these
stories how complicated supply chains
are and how much everything is connected
you know we had a few weeks ago we had
the gas prices led to a carbon dioxide
shortage which led to a chicken
shortage and the government had to step
in they essentially subsidize the costs
of the production of that carbon dioxide
uh
it's now gas prices are continuing to
rise there's no real let up in sight
rushing a pipeline using prices as a
bargaining chip around a pipeline that
they want to build to bypass ukraine so
that there's no magic way to bring gas
prices down and of course shortages in
consumer goods shortages in business
goods
all
drive inflation even further we knew
that there would be a burst of inflation
as the global economy came back to life
but most of the chief economists of
banks around the world said they thought
it would be temporary the fear is
particular a because we've added all of
this friction to our trade borders
because of brexit that we and and labor
shortages that we end up with inflation
that we can't control and let's just
have a quick look at the star uh they
describe it as crunch time we've
survived fuel pigs co2 and lorry crises
but how will we cope with this new hail
saying that crisps are now facing uh
price hikes but i wanted
before we run out of time uh christopher
to the ft
uh brussels offering to ease tensions
with plans for fewer controls across the
irish sea this is about the so-called
sausage wars
yeah and it's not just sausages there's
other food products too that can't go
currently between or won't shortly when
this grace period ends between great
britain and northern ireland um this
shows to me that this hardball that the
government's playing that we're
expecting some big moment in the in
early november
when uh lord frost the brexit minister
may even rip up this protocol and impose
our own protocol like trigger article 16
this shows i think that brussels is
getting nervous um the final day newmar
of the brexit saga i think is is is
within weeks away now and i think this
is a bit shows that over in brussels
they're worried about it and then
they're offering new new ways to stop
doing so many checks on things going
across the rsc the uk claims that that's
caused all the problems or a lot of
problems in northern ireland that's
disputed by the european union but that
but this is where it is it's it's
numbers and volumes of checks between
the two islands of gb and northern and
ireland
a very quick thought from you um is this
a victory for for lord frost and his
negotiations polly
uh
i mean you know the bombast and the
bluster and uh
and they're in the end backing down is
basically lord frost's uh negotiating
techniques this is good good progress
basically sausages and other traditional
british products we have to have a big
old union jack on them marks uk only and
not been permitted to cross the border
you know it sounds like the beginnings
of a good solution that um will allow
more northern irish people to have more
sausages
good
okay